ladies and gentle have the result of the
Rochdale parliamentary election I Steve
rumlow in the acting returning officer
at the above election do declare and
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate the said
election is as follows Christopher
Michael Baxter UK Independence Party you
cape 1641 simon dan jock 883 Jane
Elizabeth and Howard Conservative Party
candidate fourteen thousand two hundred
sixty Andrew John Kelly Liberal
Democrats 4027 handy little would
Greater Manchester homeless voice 242
[Applause]
Anthony Joseph Lloyd Labour Party 29,035
[Music]
[Music]
the turnout the election was sixty four
point two four percent thank you mister
returning officer can I begin both as a
duty but also was a pleasure in thanking
you and all your staff firms here
tonight who are always beyond Seoul
untold and heroes in heroin conservative
elections of course those who work
throughout the day can I say thank you
have a history of this thank you two
police officers who've kept the peace
throughout two rocks Delta today and we
depend on a police there's no very proud
of what they do for resolve and can I
give very very strong thanks to the
members of the Labour Party who worked
so hard during this campaign some of
them who have been fasting and
approaching the time where they need to
to go and eat so I'll Frank in my my
remarks brief I would simply want to say
this though that the Welcome I've
received across Rochdale I think has
been tremendous both for me personally
but actually for the for the politics
the very positive politics that labor is
espoused it's very clear that the people
of roxelle are rightly proud of this
town rightly proud of what Rochdale is
all about want a better voice a stronger
voice for the great things that rots
know represents in so many aspects of
life and I am humbled they're genuinely
humbled with the food the duty but the
pleasure to fight for the people of
Rockville but they've also made it very
clear that they reject that the politics
of negativity those candidates who
campaign only on negative politics have
been dismissed out of hand by the people
of lobster that's good for politics and
they've also made it clear though they
want something better than the politics
of austerity which has done so much
damage to this town to its health
services education services of the
public services and I will be there to
put the case for something better for
this great town Rock Steel is a great
town
the town of wonderful people have met
many of them over the last few weeks I
honestly thought I'd be on holiday at
the moment so this election wasn't
necessary but this election has given
the people of Rock still the chance to
say they won't change and I'm proud to
be part of that change and I'm proud of
the people those in this room and
elsewhere who made that possible tonight
so mister returning officer thank you
once again to you and thank you to
everybody who's made this election such
a great - a great opportunity for the
people of Rock still to have their voice
[Applause]
[Music]